with a population of over 30 million
people kuru is the fourth biggest
country in latin america and one of the
richest countries in the world in terms
of biodiversity and natural resources in
this vast and Xion country we can find
among other things the biggest silver
reserves the third biggest zinc and
copper reserves as well as the sixth
biggest gold reserves in the world in
today's video we're going to be talking
all about Peru equal treat our visuals
politic
you
now Peru is still a poor country and
there is still a lot of work to be done
when it comes to its industrial
framework but despite this Peru stands
out among its Latin American neighbors
as an example of reforms done right and
some favors if this process continues
with soon going to be talking about Peru
as a great Latin American power Lima its
capital city already has a higher GDP
than Bolivia its anomic people in the
last decade Peru has recorded the second
biggest growth rate of all countries in
Latin America in the same period its GDP
has more than double the investment rate
has gone from 13% of GDP to 20% and the
poverty rate this is the percentage of
people who can't afford basic things
like food clothes education and health
care has dropped from rates of over 50%
in the year 2000 to just 22% today this
is a reduction of more than half which
is not bad at all the country with a
higher poverty reduction rate in Latin
America during the last 13 years and say
on top of all that Peru is one of the
least indebted countries in Latin
America and in fact is one of the least
indebted in the whole world this is due
to a strong determination to use public
funds responsibly this is an achievement
of Peru's previous government which were
led by orient sir mala Alan Garcia and
Alejandro Toledo because of these
leaders the public debt has been reduced
to less than 50% since the year 2000
[Music]
but better still how did it reach a
political consensus that maintain
stability with the government budget
while also making pro market policy yeah
but one more anime via energy as we see
for yourself butter those mix forty
Robert Bellarmine senior with there are
others now this is probably one of the
most interesting things about Peru and
it's also where they can see other
countries invaluable lesson we recently
made a video talking about the disaster
that is Venezuela but the interesting
thing is the Peru's economic situation
was pretty similar to Venezuela's in the
1980s so let's have a look at what 85
[Music]
in the 1970s and the beginning of the
1980s the Peruvian government bet on
boosting the Peruvian economy through
public investment they wanted to replace
imports and to restrict the sale of
foreign product to achieve this they had
to borrow money which shot up the public
debt the results were so bad but when
the oil crisis happened in 1979 and
their economic growth slowed down Peru's
government started to have so many
problems that in 1983 they had to
suspend their payments to their debtors
in other words they failed to pay their
debts because they ran out of money and
the Peruvian government collapsed from
that moment things went from bad to
worse and when Alan Garcia came to power
in 1985 the entire country was a bit of
a disaster this is when the government
started to intervene on a massive scale
they started fixing prices and in the
labor markets they reinforced the
important policies which limited the
number of products that were available
to buy and setting an average tariff
which reached 66% of a summit attempt
another one was young I am Sousa the
public deficit went through the roof and
the informal economy became the norm so
even though there were more than a
hundred taxes the state simply couldn't
collect them and on top of all that the
government had collapsed so no one
wanted to lend them money now you might
be wondering what exactly did Peru do
well they started to print more money
which basically made the indc Peruvian
currency worse about as much as monopoly
money
as if all of that wasn't enough for Peru
today always they also have to deal with
the narco traffic and terrorist actions
by groups such as M RTA and Sendero
Luminoso which were causing tens of
thousands of deaths all across the
country any area judicata Centro de
operaciones en la zona de la selva noir
oriental busca una Alianza strategy
cacao as Vandiver narco traffic on tape
well what was the result of all this
well by the end of the decade GDP had
dropped by 25 cents further its GDP per
capita with similar to the 1960s and
inflation every year was about seven
thousand five hundred percent it was at
this point that the World Bank
recognized Peru as one of the poorest
countries in the world Amitabh Bachchan
say Cinco quanto for Tony Lee toric holy
SH 18 Tehama face Indian troll aina o tu
esposa difficult possibility of a hos
quadrotor me no Ilana no saki locally
viento video me receive so thank you and
he was recording the situation was so
grave that the World Bank estimates that
if this has never happened pairing of
GDP and purchasing power parity would
today be similar to Italy's Spain or
South Korea's no more no less in many
ways the crisis that Peru faced was very
similar to the crisis facing Venezuela
today for example you can see lots of
public spending plenty of taxes lots of
printing money are dropping the price of
commodities oh and also plenty of
violence so when we released our video
about Venezuela many people asked what
we would do to solve the problems well
let's have a look up to room
[Music]
way too serious in 1990 a strong plan of
reforms and economic stabilization began
and in fact this is the same plan that
really does still exist today it passed
through the following stages in order to
slow down inflation first of all the EMT
was replaced by a new currency the new
soul in addition to this the
dollarization of the economy was allowed
which is essentially where US dollars
are used in dates of a national currency
from that moment monetary stability in
the country became a national priority
the tax system was changed and greatly
simplified with the elimination of 64
taxes further the pension system was
also reformed and the Chilean system was
used as a model but there were also many
improvements made this is actually quite
a controversial topic and something that
we're going to be addressing in a future
visual politic video so don't forget to
subscribe
further an ambitious program to attract
investors and privatized public
utilities was put into motion
soon companies such as Aero Peru electro
Lima and the Peruvian telephone company
were put into private hands a trade open
the strategy was put into place which
reduced that ridiculously high 66
percent tariff to something closer to
1.5 percent at the same time as this
happened numerous free trade deals were
signed including very important ones
with the United States as well as the
European Union then in 2002 a gradual
decentralization of power started
happening the result of this was that
most public investment spending today
happens with regions and municipality
and finally and probably the most
important point was their commitment to
budgetary stability this is something
that since it was put into place every
government has respected pero register
on super avec des col des des des portes
own elementary maestro Delano esto como
consecuencia de la mentor lost ingresos
del gobierno young crostini economic
Osasco nero actually in 1999 a law which
put in the place called the fiscal
transparency and prudence law this
restricts the discretionary power of
government to spend more than they
receive this includes corrective
elements for public deficit situation
many experts on the subject can test
this is one of the most important laws
in the history of Peru but it's not all
roses don't think that we've forgotten
League dark side of Peru this was
amazing like these cells Berto cookie
Maurice regime this was an authoritarian
regime and the president of it is now
serving a 25 year jail term he was
convicted for crimes against humanity
and corruption what's important to keep
in mind is the situation that Venezuela
faces today is similar to the situation
that Peru faced so keep in mind there's
always a way out
[Music]
hello today and tomorrow so now you
might have in your mind the question why
is Peru still a poor country today as we
said at the beginning of this video the
institutional shortfalls and the
challenges that Peru faces today are
many among them we can't stress enough
the high degree of legal uncertainty and
corruption this is something that we can
definitely see with the death squads
case this is where under Tomales regime
from 2011 to 2015 a group of policemen
killed innocent people for money those
kills included a general and a major
from Peru's National Police further
there are extremely high levels of crime
and there's also the chance that the
mining industry will face the same Renzi
a problems that Chile faces today not to
mention there is a very sharp difference
between the living standards in
different regions on the 5th of June
2016 the second round of presidential
elections were held where Pedro Pablo
Kaczynski was elected as the new
president of the Republic of Peru these
elections were the closest in Peru's
history and truces in ski beat out his
rival Keiko Fujimori who by the way is
Alberto Fujimori daughter he beat a by
just 40,000 votes the policies announced
by Kaczynski includes to keep working on
the agenda of pushing competitiveness
and trade openness in this regard he is
pledged to reduce tax by 10 percent for
SMEs that small or medium sized
enterprises as well as battle against
bureaucracy remove unnecessary
regulation and to pursue regional
economic integration
similar to the TPP or RCEP led by China
if Kavinsky gets to remain at the helm
and fight all of the problems that are
affecting peru despite his relative
political weakness because they're not
very friendly congress i'm sure that the
growth of peru will continue and will
remain a leader in growth so latin
america and maybe in a few years peru
which is a young nation with an average
age of 27 could follow the example of
the Asian Tigers and get transformed
into a major global power so that is our
opinion here a visual politic and we
would love to know what you think will
Peru be able to leave poverty behind and
become an economic powerhouse and is
Kosinski the ideal person to achieve
this let us know your opinion in the
comments below and also if you did like
this video please do hit that like
button below and don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday and I'll see you
next time or as they say in Quechua to
Panama cheeks amar
[Music]
you